quando ho saputo il tema del ted di
quest'anno ho pensato ad aver fatto un
gravissimo errore ad accettare non ho la
più pallida idea di come saranno le
città nel 2039
non ho la più pallida idea di come sarà
la società in cui vivremo se ci pensate
gran parte delle previsioni che sono
state fatte negli ultimi anni poi non si
sono avverate
nessuno aveva previsto internet
nessuno probabilmente aveva previsto la
break sito sovrani smo con questa con
questa facilità quindi volevo iniziare
con una provocazione e ci avevo pensato
fino a pochi giorni fa salire sul palco
con la slide che trovate le mie spalle
dove c'è scritto il futuro non è scritto
dirvi che era compito di tutti noi
provare a scrivere il futuro che ci
aspetta è scendere avreste partecipato
al ted più col più corto della storia
quello di cui vi voglio invece parlare
però è quello che sto cercando di
costruire con il mio gruppo di ricerca e
in particolare vi voglio parlare di
quello che si può fare oggi con
l'intelligenza artificiale per capire le
città e per capire cosa funziona e cosa
non funziona nelle città perché le città
perché ci sono dei trend a cui non
possiamo non non credere ad esempio le
nazioni unite ci hanno detto che nel
noi avremmo 43 megalopoli cioè città con
più di 10 milioni di abitanti nel 2050
due persone su tre vivranno all'interno
di città quindi lasceranno la realtà
rurale si sposteranno in città questo
che effettua sul che effetti ha effetti
positivi effetti negativi c'è una
semplice legge che alcuni fisici del
santa fe institute hanno elaborato che
si chiama equazione di scala e dice che
all'aumento della popolazione al
raddoppio della popolazione
quello che succede che ci sono degli
effetti positivi in maniera super
lineare cioè non sono solamente il
doppio ma qualcosa in più il 15 per
cento in più
questo significa che se una città
diventa due volte più grande diventerà
più di due volte più ricca diventerà più
di due volte più creativa
quindi le città più grandi sono quelle
più creative le città più grandi sono
anche quelle dove la ricchezza e
maggiore ma ci sono solo aspetti
positivi o anche aspetti negativi in
realtà non ci sono solo aspetti positivi
ad esempio le città più grandi sono
anche le città dove il numero di crimini
è maggiore le città più grandi sono
anche il numero delle città in cui la
capacità di inquinamento è maggiore la
velocità con cui si diffondano epidemie
e maggiore quello che quindi abbiamo
cercato di fare con il mio gruppo di
ricerca e cercare di capire qualcosa in
più rispetto a questa semplice legge ci
siamo chiesti che cosa rende una città
vivibile è una città no ad esempio che
cosa fa sì che tutti voi tutti noi
vorremmo passare del tempo probabilmente
a new york ma non a detroit per fare
questo ci siamo rifatti non sa qualcosa
del futuro ma qualcosa del passato
siamo partiti da una teoria di un
attivista urbana che si chiama jane
jacobs che negli anni sessanta scritto
un libro fantastico che si chiama la
vita e la morte delle grandi città
americane
in questo libro lei cerca di spiegare
che cosa rende un quartiere vivo e che
cosa invece non rende impossibile la
vita la vitalità di un quartiere per
jane jacobs è data dalla possibilità di
avere un continuo scambio di relazioni
ed interazioni nel quartiere di avere
pedoni tutto il tempo di avere quello
che lei chiama un balletto un balletto
che avviene durante tutta la giornata
le persone si incontrano scambiano idee
litigano c'è innovazione
questa è l'idea essenzialmente di
quartiere
di jane jacobs e questa comunità che si
crea anche una comunità che rende la
città più sicura perché questa cosa
avvenga jane jacobs aveva identificato
quattro condizioni un quartiere di
questo genere deve ancora essere un
quartiere molto attrattivo dove molta
gente vuole andare a vivere dove molta
gente vuole andare a lavorare quindi
deve esserci quello che i fisici avevano
individuato deve essere un posto dove
molte persone abitano e vanno a lavorare
un'altra condizione è che in un
quartiere di questo genere deve esserci
una certa struttura della città devono
esserci piazze devono esserci molti
incroci devono esserci luoghi in cui
potersi incontrare un quartiere di
questo genere poi deve avere più di una
funzionalità deve essere non solamente
il posto dove si va a dormire
quindi non deve essere un quartiere
dormitorio solamente residenziale non
deve essere il posto dove si va
solamente a lavorare quindi un posto di
grandi aziende grandi fabbriche non deve
essere il posto dove ci sono solamente
grandi centri commerciali ma devono
esserci tutte e tre queste cose allo
stesso tempo la quarta condizione poi
che deve essere un quartiere in grado di
attirare persone differenti differenti
per obiettivi differenti per
e condizioni socio economiche deve
essere un quartiere che è in grado di
avere anche diverse tipi di attività
economiche deve essere il piccolo
negozio insieme alla grande azienda
queste sono le condizioni che secondo
jane jacobs rendono un quartiere un
quartiere vitale però questa era una
teoria che era stata scritta in realtà
per salvare un quartiere che ra
greenwich village ma non era mai stata
provata ma è stata testata quello che
abbiamo fatto con il mio gruppo di
ricerca e partire dai dati che oggi noi
possediamo cioè la grande quantità di
tracce digitali che lasciamo ad esempio
con l'uso dei nostri cellulari che ci
dicono dove passiamo il tempo i luoghi
che frequentiamo e anche le altre
informazioni che si possono ricavare ad
esempio le informazioni sulla struttura
di una città che possiamo avere da una
mappa come open street map che è un
google map aperto e costruito dal dalle
persone oppure le informazioni sui
luoghi che possiamo ottenere da
foursquare
le immagini che possiamo avere da google
street view
unendo tutte queste informazioni un
utilizzando gli algoritmi di
intelligenza artificiale
siamo stati in grado di validare le
teorie di jane jacobs e di capire
veramente che cosa funziona e non
funziona all'interno di una città capire
ad esempio l'importanza che ha la
diversità di persone che frequentano un
quartiere sulla città di londra siamo
riusciti a dimostrare che avviene un
quartiere con queste caratteristiche
vuol dire avere un quartiere con meno
crimini un quartiere più sicuro ma conta
solamente come una città è costruita
come una città è fatta o conta anche
l'aspetto estetico di una città molti di
voi posti davanti a questa domanda è se
dovessero decidere dove passeggiare
sceglierebbero sicuramente una delle due
strade quella che appare più sicura non
quella che appare
meno sicura questo è quello che ha fatto
come studio le mitiche ha deciso di
chiedere a persone come noi di decidere
davanti a coppie di strade prese da
google street view di scegliere quale
delle due veniva percepita come più
sicura e questo è stato fatto per la
gran parte delle città del mondo
il problema è che però fare in questo
modo con questo strumento significava
avere pochissimi voti per pochissime
strade in giro per il mondo e questo non
basta perché a noi ci interesserebbe
avere un'informazione di questo tipo per
ogni città e per ogni strada di ogni
città e per fare questo quello che si
può utilizzare è l'intelligenza
artificiale si può utilizzare la visione
la visione artificiale la computer
vision si possono dare queste immagini
in pasto a degli algoritmi che siano
loro a decidere di attribuire un
punteggio di sicurezza percepita
imparando da quello che hanno fatto
prima di loro gli umani allora quello
che abbiamo fatto è stato costruire un
algoritmo di questo genere e per diverse
città italiane siamo stati in grado per
ogni strada di dire quale del quale era
il livello di sicurezza percepita della
strada
una volta che abbiamo fatto questo ci
siamo chiesti ma questo qui ha un
effetto realmente in come le persone
passano il tempo all'interno di quella
strada che abbiamo utilizzato un altra
sorgente di dati che oggi a disposizione
abbiamo utilizzato i dati dai cellulari
e siamo stati in grado di predire che
tipo di persone c'erano semplicemente
dalla percezione di sicurezza di un
luogo abbiamo scoperto che ad esempio
luoghi percepiti come più sicuri sono
luoghi dove c'è una maggioranza di
persone anziane c'è una maggioranza di
donne molto di più rispetto a quelle che
realmente vivono in quel posto
passano il loro tempo in luoghi che sono
percepiti come sicuri
poi abbiamo fatto un'altra cosa ci siamo
chiesti ma come decide l'algoritmo che
assegna questi punteggi di sicurezza che
cosa utilizza per decidere e quindi
abbiamo foscato parte di queste immagini
abbiamo cercato di capire quali erano le
decisioni che l'algoritmo prendeva e ci
siamo accorti che ci sono alcune
caratteristiche di come appaiono nelle
nostre città che sono fondamentali
ad esempio l'aver e dei giardini ben
curati all avere certe strutture delle
case le case che hanno balconi molto
evidenti che si affacciano sulla sulla
strada sono strade che permettono e
danno una percezione di sicurezza
maggiore agli abitanti e questa è una
teoria che per molto tempo è stata in
voga nelle teorie dell'urbanistica ma
che nessuno prima aveva validato e che
il nostro algoritmo è stato in grado di
validare ma adesso abbiamo quindi tutti
gli strumenti per capire cosa funziona e
cosa non funziona all'interno di una
città quali sono gli elementi che
funzionano quelli che non funzionano
quali sono i comportamenti che vanno
bene quelli che vanno meno bene ma basta
questa cosa qui l'intelligenza
artificiale ci può permettere anche di
fare altro in realtà si l'intelligenza
artificiale ci può permettere
utilizzando
le generativa others all'iran network
quindi il deep learning ci può
permettere di costruire delle città
ideali imparando che cosa va bene che
cosa non va bene per una città
noi siamo in grado oggi di generare
immagini video e strutture fisiche di
quelle che sarebbero le città ideali
siamo in grado di capire come una città
come roma può mantenendo la sua vitalità
la brillantezza dei suoi quartieri lo
scambio e la gioia dei suoi abitanti
diventare anche una città meno inquinata
meno trafficata e via dicendo che cosa
può servire per fare questo e lo
possiamo costruire con degli algoritmi
prima di portarlo nella vita reale
questi strumenti dovrebbero diventare
oggi qualcosa che è strumento non solo
dei ricercatori dovrebbero uscire
dovrebbero diventare strumenti dei delle
persone che prendono le decisioni
strumenti dei cittadini che dovrebbero
vedere che cosa succede se si cambia un
pezzo della loro città quali sono gli
effetti che possono in questo modo
decidere insieme ai politici e decisori
quindi come vi avevo detto all'inizio io
non ho la più pallida idea se nel 2039
noi avremo macchine volanti alla maniera
di blade runner avremmo una città con
porti in ognuno dei grattacieli
questo non lo so so che oggi abbiamo
tutti gli strumenti per capire che cosa
funziona e non funziona di un quartiere
di una città
abbiamo anche gli strumenti per
costruire costruire una città ideale che
qualcosa a cui gli esseri umani hanno
sempre cercato di arrivare a una città
ideale che dovrebbe essere non una città
ideale per deforme una città
intelligente produttiva dovrebbe essere
la città che soddisfa come direbbe jane
jacobs le esigenze di tutti i suoi
abitanti non solo di una parte di tutti
buone esplorazioni di futuro e buone
costruzioni futuro grazie
[Applauso]